à lire à béton campagne avec sa liste
pour que tu rates respire parmi ces
actions des rencontres avec les
trappistes pour discuter de son
programme et de leurs attentes ou 1 ce
qui m'intéresse le plus c'est pour les
jeunes et l'huile et il travaille pour
çà n'est trucs pour les handicapés une
alliée du tube pour les handicapés
attrape les priorités sont les mêmes le
logement la sécurité l'emploi les
personnes âgées l'éducation des enfants
ce qui est vraiment au coeur de la vie
des habitants des trente deux mille
habitants de la ville de trappes et sur
lesquels nous avons beaucoup de progrès
à réaliser la ville de trappes as
parfois était immobile lors des mandats
précédents il faut maintenant faire
preuve de volontarisme et mettre
énormément d'énergie pour moderniser
cette ville et lui donner les mêmes
droits que tout les autres comme axe
prioritaire du candidat de gauche le
logement ici à trappes nous avons
beaucoup de logements de logements
sociaux qui sont parfois mal entretenues
par les propriétaires par les bailleurs
sociaux y compris et donc nous nous
battons aux côtés des habitants des
amicales de locataires qui se
constituent pour faire respecter le
droit des habitants c'est un peu le pot
de fer contre le pot de terre et le rôle
de la mairie c'est de venir soutenir et
renforcer les locataires en soutenant
leurs droits et en obtenant des
bailleurs ce que nous avons déjà réussi
à obtenir pendant l'année écoulée des
investissements pour rattraper le retard
à les rabais aura pu profiter également
de cette matinée pour dresser un bilan
d'une année passée en tant que maire de
la commune avant l'annulation du scrutin
on a mis en oeuvre énormément de choses
damman sur l'éducation avec le retour du
soutien scolaire
le retour d'activités périscolaires de
qualité l'union de gauche que mène à
lire à b aura comme principal adversaire
l'alliance entre manas roues guy
malandain et mustapha larbaoui au
scrutin des 10 et 17 octobre prochains